he's interesting Peter showed me some
kid who was on I guess he has his
YouTube channel or something he made a
video it makes a series of short films
and the one I saw was he was dressed up
as a woman and he was doing what is
really a very old-fashioned
he was doing an update of a very old
fashioned for less sketch were you know
guys dressed up as women and did like
little stick and he got some kind of
reality TV show deal or something and I
told my students that he had like
800,000 like 7 million hits okay and
they said that's not that big a number
it compared to what some people get
there's a blogger who got a TV series
but but there's a new phrase now that
they using come vlogging maybe you know
yeah but what I find really fascinating
about this is that people young people
and I mean like 20 year olds look at
this and think it's new when in fact and
I think one of my missions as a teacher
is to give them a frame of reference
then they'll make better product if you
know what's come before you're you're
gonna build on it rather than think
you've created and and so I watched this
thing as a sort of an object lesson and
I said this goes back to vaudeville to
the British music halls to to burlesque
this is not new this is a new take on
that I don't know whether this kid
actually that my bet is he had not he
just thinks he's really funny you know
it's kind of it you know but it's really
stupid and I mean it's really stupid
I've seen some good vloggers and you
know good sketches Margaret Cho took a
guy on the road that she and I saw I saw
him open for a guy who did this thing he
dressed up as a girl this is like four
or five years ago he had a viral of
video that went viral it was like let me
wear that sweater and and she took him
on the road
to help his career and yeah I don't know
where he is now but he had this song
everybody in the audience I mean my wife
and I were the oldest people in the
audience and everybody was singing the
lyrics of the song they all of you too
so the world has changed but I would
just like people to know the references
they're making whether they realize it
or not so that they can do something
really original because I assure you
that and these are some comedy guys but
Sorkin and and Alan Ball and you know
Elaine May and all these people they
know their history Sherwood Schwartz
knew his history Leonard Stern newest
history and and I think Woody Allen you
could be sure what do y'all and knows
the history Albert Brooks and also we
see constantly we're watching sitcoms
these comedy writers have an incredible
backlog of you know if you ask a
musician you know every every jazz
musician can tell you the chords to all
the standards and all the classical
musicians can play depending on the kind
of music they play whether it's Bach or
Mozart or and these writers know all the
old jokes and they have a blog they know
everything and we Jeffrey and I are
always marvel at how they take classical
jokes and then update them don't tell me
that the Jack Benny story oh well that
is a great story
the famous radio joke the Jack Benny
radio joke from the 40s is he's in an
alley he's being mugged and it's the
longest silence in radio history to this
day nobody topped it and then and though
the robber says your money or your life
and there's this long long pause in
there and the guy says again I said your
money or your life and another even
longer pause and Jack Benny says I'm
thinking I'm thinking
well Roseann was doing a show why don't
you tell that part of the story we love
Bob Meyer there's the showrunner for
Roseanne and they used that joke what
they did was they had Roseanne pregnant
with her third child on the show and she
was taking a Lamaze class and that's a
do I really want to go through natural
childbirth the third time it was so
painful so she tells her her doctor
let's try some painkillers this time so
he says to her you know with your weight
you could endanger your health or the
child with the child's health what would
you like to do I said what I'm thinking
and again very funny joke but if you
knew your history you know where it came
from
later I saw the same joke and Big Bang
Theory so again it's it's nice to know
that all this material is out there
waiting to be updated waiting to be mean
the vlogger that the Jeffrey was talking
about was basically doing Milton Berle
right who was doing burlesque right who
was just money came out of Milton Berle
so it's knowing your history it's one of
the things that makes so Jeffrey really
angry is when kids are presenting
screenplays and they have no
understanding of the history of the
genre that they're due well it's it
they'll come in with an idea that they
think is totally completely original and
then someone else in the clan always
pleases me when someone else in the
class rather than me I'm going to be the
bad guy says oh you know that's like
that movie in the 1950s well you know
not that you couldn't do a new spin on
it but you should know it you know it's
it's kind of I to me it's akin to being
a primitive artist a primitive yes it's
beautiful but the skills are limited
whereas you know if you've studied art
history even a little bit you have a
sense
what you know what our different kinds
of brushstrokes why why do artists paint
in different schools different ways and
I think how can you be hurt by having
knowledge that's mean in any field there
was a famous story that George Martin
the producer for the Beatles was doing a
session with them and they were doing
she loves you and at the end they said
George invented a new chord and George
Martin laughed and said yes in a six
there's a sixth chord it was like a
standard chord every good jazz musician
knows and yeah a good classical musician
knows and he figured it out
and he invented a new chord that the
whole world that was educated new you
know that Paul's dad was in the British
music halls so Paul was second
generation and so probably grew up with
some of that just like um Billy
Crystal's parents were in the business
Jerry Lewis's parents were in the
business Albert Brooks his dad was a guy
named well his I don't know his real
name was Einstein cuz that is Albert
Brooks his real name would be Albert
Einstein but his his showbiz name was
Park your carcass so and his brother is
the guy gave never seen curb curb your
enthusiasm okay and we have to work on
you we have to get her to watch some
good teeth that's a great show by the
way
well his brother is a regular on it
there's a guy named Bob Einstein but he
also he also had another bit that he did
Bob Einstein oh he played a kind of Dave
the daredevil yeah he was sort of doing
that real he was doing a spin a take-off
on the real guy that Mikey dummy anyons
and he had a shot
very early in showtimes history he had a
Showtime series Super Dave Osborne Super
Dave my energy anyway your turn
you